and finally the last method that we are
going to see is basically how to use the
rego or the RNA I gene and reaching
ranking and the disease to identify the
heat from the RNA library screen now for
the arica analysis
unlike the z-score in the RSA which you
can actually use the z-score as the
input now for the Ricoh basically if you
look at the word document file that I
sent to you basically you need to create
these four columns in the new excel
sheets so I'm going to create that
basically now so that's in the new excel
sheet document so I'm going to put it
here now so you will have the reference
simple and then you also have two
additional column for your data one is
actually the control another one is for
the treatment now in our case if you
remember correctly so if I go back to
the original dataset here basically for
each cell lines after you have extracted
you actually have the column name as
plasmid and also sample obviously plasma
is actually the control where as the
sample is actually the the enrichment or
the depletion of the shrna following a
prolonged period of culture and this is
actually somewhat similar to the treated
data so for our analysis what we need to
do is basically of course these are just
the shrna count
we haven't actually normalized it now
for us to actually use the rigor and the
disease we have to go back to the output
file that we receive from the shrna sake
basically so if you go back to the
output file that we have you will
actually get a output file from the
shrnas sake that looks something like
this i can copy this and then put it
into a new excel sheet for you to see it
clearer so basically you will get an
excel sheet something similar
like this this is actually the output
file from the shRNA say well remember in
the output file or the while we actually
didn't change the hater so the time to
rate cows or wrap to basically or
basically whatever that referred to time
time to was actually referred to the
sample okay in our dataset but as a time
one is actually the plasmid or the
control so then you follow by this
column here you will see time to
normalize okay so and then you also have
the time one normalize here so we will
actually use the data as the the
normalize data from these two columns to
input into the input file for the reader
so okay before we do that okay so we are
going to copy okay for example this is
from px PC tree basically so we are
going to create an input file here
reference I'm just going to use the TRC
number all right and then for the gene
what is the next column okay the next
one is actually symbol so I'm going to
copy the gene symbol here and then to
put it here and then after that I'm
going to create this this will be
plasmid which is the control and muscle
sample okay now remember okay so do
mix-up here this is the critical part
because the time to this is actually
your sample data okay so you put it into
here and then the time one is actually
your plasmid data so if you swap it so
then your data will come up directly
opposite basically okay here you go so
you have the first input file for the
arica so I'm going to save it now and
the certain folder so I'm going to save
save it as
the ash folder here my South Rica so I'm
going to save it as input now
be careful is that well okay because
this was the Ricoh was actually created
some time ago so it wouldn't recognize a
new Excel workbook format instead what
you need to do is that you have to save
it under the excel 97-2003 workbook so
you can save it okay okay once you have
done saving it now we are going to open
the Eureka or the what we call it the
genii software so you can download it so
in fact why I'm going to upload the
Jeannie program into the Dropbox you can
actually install it and then follow the
instruction given under the word
document this one the landing-place
analysis you have a section called Rica
it will tell you how you can actually
will you call it install the Rieger
Java file into the Jeannie extension so
anyway so well what we are going to do
now is we are going to run the gene e so
you can run it here okay so this is the
interface of the Jeannie
so wait for it okay that so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to the file and
I'm going to open file so this would be
the Rika input file that I just created
just now I'm going to input it okay now
so here it will basically preview to you
the data set that you have but you need
to select which one is the row method
data column at the data and the data
matrix so in this case here the data
matrix is basically from this two column
onwards so I'm going to put the mark
here what it says here basically this is
consider row metadata and the pink color
column metadata and the blue color is
the actual data matrix that I have so
I'm going to press ok here then it will
generate a type of heat map like this
you don't have to bother too much about
it so the next thing what I'm going to
do is I'm going into
and I'm going to run the reader here
okay so then you will get this interface
so what is important here is basically
you need to I tell the reader out how
the Jeannie program which one do you
want to compare to so a notation I will
be based on reference so when you click
it there's two selection here basically
the class a will be the control which is
the plasmid and then the Class B would
be the sample here okay
now there are many metrics for the
ranking of the hairpin in this case here
I know I normally prefer to use the lot
for change okay number of permutation we
will leave it at one thousand method to
call what happens to gene so I'm going
to use the second best rank algorithm
here okay and then this one I can leave
it as it is so this one okay all these
are such basically I just need to press
ok ok it is done now basically so now
but it does it's very similar to the RSA
it collects all the individual shrna
score into a single p-value that
representing each gene to look at the
data basically you can go here and then
you right click then you can actually
look at gene report here so that will
show you basically the data for example
okay in this case here I tsn2 they are
quite a number of hair pins okay so you
don't have to worry too much about it
but again the one that we will pay
attention to will be the p-value here if
you want you can actually save this data
basically you can save it as output here
under this under the same folder then
you can open it in the excel to look at
it much more clearer so I'm going into
the recur here okay and
output you can open it using the notepad
so you can then copy this into the excel
file if you want to look at that so
that's here you go
so you can see that okay this is a gene
name this is the different hair pins
that target the particular genes there
are altogether 15 hair pins and these
are the rank of the individual hair pins
and then okay the p-value here that you
have basically and this is the most
important column that we are going to
focus on and again once we have done
that we are going to put that into the
master data file that we have we can
create one additional sheet here and
labor as rigor okay and of course then
the gene lists
I can copy here and then the cell lines
I can copy it over here so the next
thing is that you can actually copy the
genes and also the p-value here you can
put it into a separate column and again
using a we look up okay to column two
and four okay so when you do that and
you copy all the way down so then you
will have your p-value for each of for
each of the cell lines here okay so it's
almost well it's quite straightforward
so by now you should have completed okay
tree and the disease one is using the z
score beta is a cut-off order or the
mean or or you can use RSA and finally
you should have also the data for the
Rika as well thank you